you
ever wondered how to scale your
application to millions of users with
open source Technologies and how to
choose a database that will give you
both openness and scalability let's see
how alloy DB for postgres merges the
best parts of postgres and Google Cloud
to do just that
building an application is different
today than it was a few years ago the
cloud enables global scale and Rapid
iteration and offers many database
choices so if you're building an
application today you're in luck
but because of fundamental trade-offs
around cost functionality and
performance choosing the right one to
support your workload can be a challenge
no matter what you're building you
probably want your database to be fully
managed and your developers to be more
productive by standardizing on open
source Technologies or maybe you're
migrating existing workloads to the
cloud and are looking to change up how
you're managing your data you're no
longer willing to tolerate opaque costs
overpriced and restrictive licensing and
vendor lock-in you want an Engaged
Community that's constantly adding
features and extensions to support a
variety of workloads for Enterprise
workloads postgres is growing across
Industries as an open standard
alleviating the fear of being locked
into a specific vendor but as awesome as
postgres is it could do so much more to
use the power of the cloud what if it
could take advantage of scale out
storage and compute massive amounts of
memory or AIML powered management and
configuration what if that management
and configuration could eliminate steps
like tuning of database parameters Auto
vacuum management and worrying about
scaling while maintaining full postgres
compatibility
built for scale using Google's
first-hand experience developing global
scale storage systems alloy DB has been
built to be fully compatible with
existing postgres workloads meaning your
application doesn't need to change once
it's comfortable speaking postgres
we've custom built the storage engine to
be database aware optimized for storing
postgres data and storage is independent
from compute so each can scale
independently of the other that allows
alloy DB to meet the needs of
applications with a variety of usage
patterns
compute has gotten the same treatment to
storage and is custom designed and built
to be database aware each database can
have a read replica pool that you can
scale up and down and all of the nodes
share the underlying storage for low
latency access
alodb automatically rebalances load
across all the nodes in the pool
allowing it to smooth out spikes giving
consistent strong and predictable
performance
all these changes combined provide an
overall boost in performance providing
more than four times the performance of
standard postgres for transactional
workloads for analytical queries lodb
delivers up to a hundred times faster
performance
while we're busy handling the larger
workloads faster we're also committed to
reliability in a big way how adb's SLA
is four nines or 99.99 availability
including maintenance
and of course no Google product would be
complete without a nice dose of AIML and
other adaptive algorithms we use them
for Alloy DB vacuum management storage
and memory management data tiering and
analytic acceleration add up the
performance optimizations the scaling
for larger workloads and the reliability
guarantee allowedb is an ideal choice
for critical Enterprise class
applications that would have previously
used old-school commercial databases
scaling your relational database backend
doesn't have to be challenging or costly
any longer
Google brought the experience and
technology that built some of the
world's most popular cloud services and
applied them to a friendly and open
postgres interface with alloy DB igrate
your legacy databases build amazing new
applications and let us handle the rest
available on Google Cloud create an
instance today and connect your
application
there are links to the documentation and
getting started guides in the
description below
[Music]